(upbeat music)
- Welcome to the "Think Marketing Show."
The number one podcast for growing
and scaling your business
with online video.
I'm Heather Torres.
- And I'm Sean Cannell,
and we're from Think Media.
And if this is your first
time listening, welcome.
- This show's dedicated
to helping you learn
how to get your content noticed,
and the latest money-making strategies
working right now online.
So, whether you wanna
grow your YouTube channel,
or maximize online video
across social media,
this is for you.
So Sean, over 1.5 million
subscribers across your channels,
over a hundred million views.
How do you get views on YouTube in 2020?
- Yeah, you know, there's
been so many strategies
I've taught over the years.
But if I was to pick one going into 2020,
I would say, you need to choose
the right nitch or niche.
And what I mean by that,
and that's kind of, 101,
it seems like in marketing,
but I'm coming from a perspective of,
like if you're not in a big enough market,
if you're not talking about
topics that there's enough
interest in, then there's
not even really the potential
to get enough views.
And this is kind of a business
thinking type of a term.
There's what's known as your TAM.
That's the Total Addressable Market.
So for example, if you
do some keyword research,
which is where you could go
to Google or Ubersuggest,
or some kind of a tool,
and see how many people
search for a certain term per month,
you can get an idea for how
much interest is in a topic.
If we look up underwater
basket weaving, right?
And you look at how many
people a month are interested,
in like, it's tutorials about that,
anything about underwater basket weaving.
Last time I checked, it
was only about 8,000.
Now, if you look up something
like tech in general,
some of the topics I've talked about,
best camera for YouTube, or, you know,
the latest phone, even bigger.
Or all kinds of things in the tech world.
We're in Las Vegas, so the
CES show is here once a year.
We always cover that ourselves
and the Think Media team.
Tech is massive.
I mean 200,000 people come to Vegas.
Billions of people around the
world are looking for that,
whereas only 8,000 are looking
for underwater basket weaving.
So what I mean is you
wanna make sure that you're
in a nitch, in a niche, that
is actually going to map
to your ambition of
getting a lot of views.
So specifically, like I think about,
and it doesn't have to be massive,
but I think about people in our community
that are crushing it, like
with Video Ranking Academy
and YouTube Hypergrowth, and
these different programs.
So there's like "Plants with Lucia."
She's got a brand-new channel.
She's growing.
It's like almost 2,500 subscribers.
Well, there's so many people
into gardening, into plants.
And so she's reviewing
plants, talking about plants,
she loves plants.
So it's an actual proven
market, as opposed to,
she's not just vlogging her life
and hopes somebody gets interested.
Or picking something
too small and obscure.
You can pick something obscure,
but it may just be a hobby
and never actually turn into
something that you could
live full-time off of.
I think about your channel.
Like, "Homeschool" is not only,
a lot of people around the world doing it,
but it's hot right now, right?
- Very hot right now.
- Yeah, so people in "Homeschool"
they're asking questions about it.
So tens of thousands, hundreds
of thousands of people
are looking at "Homeschool" stuff.
You planted your flag.
So you choosed the right niche for you.
Like that's the thing, too.
This isn't just pick a, you
know, I think about Nicole.
"Kids OT Health" helping
people with newborns,
and that are in that
pregnancy and coming into
that first year, second
year of having a new child.
That's a lot of people.
Like anyone that's gonna have kids.
And so how big is your actual niche?
Julie just came to our
Mastermind and she is in network
marketing helping other
network marketing leaders
with advice and tips.
So how to grow to your
business network marketing?
Well, how many people
are in network marketing?
Hundreds of thousands and millions.
One of the biggest reasons I
see people not getting views
is their in a niche where
it's too general and muddy,
so people don't even know
what they're subscribing to.
There's just not a lot of general interest
in the topics and things
they're talking about.
Or, they're actually talking
about the wrong things
and therefore they're
not breaking through.
In 2020 and beyond, you really
need to be positioned right,
I think, on YouTube to
break through the noise.
- Yeah, that is so critical.
And one of the things that
we teach here Think Media
really is the types of videos
you should be creating.
'Cause that's a huge question, right?
Like what kind of videos
should I be creating?
So give me some tips on, you know,
if someone's trying to break through,
what types of videos
they should start with?
- So here's the strategy.
You want to answer specific questions.
And let's hit that again.
You want to answer specific questions
in your YouTube videos.
One video, one question.
So a good example would
be talking about fitness.
A lot of people want to grow
and sell network marketing.
They want to grow selling
supplements or products.
They maybe want to sell workout programs.
They want to be a coach.
It's a huge, health
and fitness is massive.
But if you were to go to YouTube,
a specific question would
be, "How to lose weight?"
But actually, no, that is not specific,
that's a very general question.
We're getting closer, because
a lot of people want to
do that, but when we
say specific questions,
it actually might be,
"How to lose weight after menopause?"
Now that's a whole different, you know,
narrowed-down type of,
well we've also cut dudes out of that.
So now we're getting more
specific in the questions
that we're answering.
Recently, somebody that was a part of some
of our deeper trainings here in Vegas
where we do like a small group Mastermind.
There was one person that has
a physical therapy business
but had not actually
made videos addressing
the 101 basics about physical therapy.
So sometimes, it's almost
like we can't see the forest
through the trees.
I feel like we need to take a step back
and answer some specific questions
that our target audience is searching.
Again, this might be 101
to some people watching,
but sometimes it's the
biggest missed opportunity.
I know after, you know starting
Think Media back in 2010,
our main channel, and then
kinda now a decade later
launching Think Marketing
and kinda getting
into this new era, we're actually
coming back to the basics
more than ever before.
We're realizing there's more
specific kinda beginner,
starter questions out there
and we're getting all fancy.
And sometimes we have to answer this,
we're actually answering questions
people aren't asking yet.
As opposed to answering the
questions they are asking
so we can help them with the
information they eventually
should be asking, but they
don't know what they don't know.
- Yeah.
- And one other way to illustrate this is,
we learned this lesson huge in tech,
was you can kinda have insider language.
For example, a lot of people
when they're shooting video
they want to have the blurry background.
Like the pretty, during Christmas,
it's like the Christmas
lights are blurry behind you.
And so a lot of people want
to have the blurry background.
Well the average is just like,
what camera gets me a blurry background?
Or, how do I get the blurry background?
Or, cool my iPhone now has
that blurry background mode.
- [Heather] Yes!
- Well, technically, that's
called depth of field.
Well, we just stepped
into some insider language
for the average person.
So people are looking for,
they want that effect and that look,
but they don't know to type in,
like how do I get depth of field,
how do I create bouquet
or bokeh, you know,
with my camera?
They're just like, can I
get the blurry behind me,
in some way?
And so, I think probably that
biggest piece of advice is
for those watching, can you,
how is your target audience
actually wording the questions?
What are the pain points
they know about now?
That's where you want to meet
them with specific videos.
And in 2020 and beyond,
that's still the opportunity, I think.
YouTube's the second largest search engine
and that's what I'd be leaning into.
- In celebration of the launch
of this brand-new podcast,
we're giving away two tickets
to our annual conference,
"Grow With Video Live."
A $1,500 value.
- All you have to do to enter
is make sure you subscribe,
leave us a review on Apple Podcasts,
and then take a screenshot
of your review and go
to ThinkMarketingShow.com
for the rest of the details.
- Yeah, I loved your advice that you gave
to the gentleman that
came to our Mastermind.
It really was like,
are you already dominating your key words?
Are you already dominating
those very specific questions?
It's not with one video, right.
How many times have you made the video,
"Best Camera for YouTube?"
- A lot.
Like once a year for six years.
- Yeah, and then down to
each individual camera.
'Cause you wanna be known as the guy
that helps you get started on YouTube.
So really specific.
But here's the big question,
because you know making videos is hard.
And pushing through that
can be a learning process in itself.
So how many videos do you need to make
before you start getting views?
- Yeah, so it's a really good question.
Because whether people are
just in our general community
or they're already like,
part of our customers,
and of course there's the
Video Ranking Academy family,
and the Inner Circle fam.
We love all of 'em.
And even when they've been through
some of our deeper training, they'll say,
"You know what, I'm doing
what you're teaching.
"I've implemented it and
it's not working yet."
And so initially, I'm
like, well shoot, okay,
how can we help, what can we do?
So then I go, well let me
go review their channel.
And I click through and I
open up their YouTube channel
and there's three videos there.
And then even more so, maybe
there's seven videos there,
but they've been a part of
our community for two years.
There's no way you're gonna break through,
or it's gonna be such a long
shot if you're gonna break
through having just posted
one video every once in awhile
over the last two years and
you're expecting break through.
There's actually kind of something
that friends of mine have researched
that run multiple
successful YouTube channels.
There's kind of a magic number
of between 30 to 55 videos
if you're starting a
YouTube channel from scratch
to just trigger the algorithm.
To kind of condition YouTube about
what kind of content you're creating.
To even give yourself a chance
to have a breakout video
to get some momentum around subscribers.
And here's what's crazy.
Like the majority of our
customers and community
have success before then,
but I'm just saying that
if you haven't even hit those number yet.
And also if you haven't hit those numbers
with some level of clarity and focus,
because YouTube wants to stereotype you.
They actually do want to
put you in a category.
So if you do a cooking video
and then you're doing a van life tour,
and then you are teaching
people how to lose weight,
and then you're reviewing a blender.
And then you're, you know,
teaching a gardening video.
YouTube's like, I don't
know where to put you.
It's not that variety
channels can't break through,
it's just much, much harder.
So you've got to post 30 to 55 videos.
Don't overthink 'em too much.
Make sure to optimize
them as much as possible,
especially when you're first starting.
So that YouTube,
'cause they don't really have
any other data about you,
except for the titles,
and the descriptions,
and the tags, and all
those types of things.
And we actually have a
video over on Think Media
about how to rank videos.
We'll link that up on the YouTube card
and so people can check that out.
That goes a little bit more
into some of those tips.
But make sure you optimize your video well
so you're giving YouTube the data,
the information about
what you're all about.
And then put in the work, put in the time.
And going into 2020, don't judge
your results if you've been
doing this for three weeks
and you only have four videos.
Furthermore, if you've been
doing this for six months,
but you upload every like, seven weeks,
and then you do two in a row,
and then you take some off.
And it's also the quality
of the uploads, you know.
If you just kinda shot
a video on your phone
that was like of your kid's graduation,
and then you did like a strategic video,
and then you did two other
videos about something else.
No, again, stop dabbling
and start dominating.
Get really focused and build momentum
and consistency with strategy.
That's how you get views in 2020.
- Thanks for checking out this episode.
We hope you got a ton of value.
And if you haven't already,
subscribe here to the
"Think Marketing Show"
wherever you're watching or listening.
- And hey, it would mean the world to us
if you would rate and review
this show on Apple Podcasts.
- As we grow this movement
of purpose-driven content
creators, we encourage you
to share it with a friend.
And we'll see you in the next episode.
(upbeat music)